ni tolérance ni indulgence encore moins
du laxisme c'est par ces mots dans les
colonnes du journal de saône et loire ce
matin que l'hôpital de sevrey défend sa
position en décembre dernier le centre
hospitalier a autorisé la sortie de
clément guérin schizophrène paranoïaque
soigné dans ses locaux
le jeune homme de 25 ans avait tué sa
mère à coup de couteau en 2016 jugé
irresponsable de ses actes il avait
alors été placé en hospitalisation
complète
la semaine dernière il a poignardé
mortellement son père et sa grand mère à
leur domicile de romenay un nouveau
passage à l'acte qui met à mal les
expertises de l'établissement spécialisé
soutenu par la direction
toutes les décisions prises ont répondu
à des objectifs thérapeutiques depuis
quatre mois
clément guérin alternait visites à
domicile et à l'hôpital un régime de
soins choisi selon une procédure définie
après expertise de plusieurs
professionnels sur ces critères un
certificat mensuel établi par le médecin
traitant une évaluation clinique tous
les six mois par deux psychiatres et une
équipe de soignants et l'avis de deux
experts nommés par la justice si le
parquet ne fait pas appel de la décision
le patient n'est alors plus interne est
aujourd'hui clément guérin est mise en
examen pour meurtre avec préméditation
il est incarcéré à lyon en unités
spécialisées